hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt bei
unserer heutigen ausgabe was koche ich
heute kochen wir buddeln wir machen
gleich unsere nudelteig selber und
werden dann ravioli es machen mit spinat
und rekord erfüllung und dazu gibt es
eine leckere tomatensoße und wir machen
die ravioli selber denn es gibt
ich werde jetzt nicht aber es geht
einfach man braucht wirklich nur ganz
wenige zutaten für den nudelteig
brauchen wir 500 gramm mehl fünf eier
und fünf esslöffel olivenöl und ich will
jetzt noch sagen wir starten direkt du
darfst es machen hier dann kommt das
medien der schüssel man kann den teig
aber auch ganz gut mit den händen
vergleichen das ganze
und auch wenn ihr das jetzt mit den
händen verknetet einfach so eine kleine
mulde ihnen das mehl machen da kommen
jetzt gleich die eier nämlich rein und
da kommt kein salz in der nudelteig weil
sich ansonsten das fett in den eiern zu
ersetzen würde haben halt keinen schönen
geschmeidigen teig dass das salz kommen
später einfach ins nudelwasser alle
haben ja im eigelb in sachen die wusste
ich allen ja deswegen darf man zum
beispiel wenn du wenn man eier trend
darf kein eigelb ins eiweiß kommen weil
er da fett drin sondern lässt sich das
eiweiß steif schlagen so alt geworden so
japan stellt mich jetzt kommen noch fünf
esslöffel olivenöl mit rein
das macht einfach den teig schön
geschmeidig kann auch anders
olivenöl passt am besten
so und jetzt darf man einfach gut
durchkneten
ganz lange kneten
ich hatte übrigens einer der größe l
also ganz große eier
übrigens die größte neuer cloris aber
falls der teig würde ich feucht genug
ist könnt ihr gern zum beispiel ein
bisschen wasser dazugeben oder am anfang
einfach etwas weniger mehl gewissen ganz
kleines bisschen mit dazu darauf nämlich
nicht zu feucht sein
das schweizer gelten
der teig ist jetzt richtig gut glatt
geworden als ich habe den so etwa sieben
bis zehn minuten kneten lassen und jetzt
freue mich ihnen zu einer kugel zusammen
und dann muss er erstmal hohen damit ihn
später gleich gut aus rollen kann also
jetzt kurz nochmals durchkneten und ich
könnte noch immer schon so dass ich
gleich eine kugel habe immer von außen
nach innen dann wirklich ihnen etwas
frischhaltefolie ein und lassen
der nudelteig steht bei mir noch im
kühlschrank nicht bereit jetzt in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die füllung vor
und zwar machen wir heute eine spinat
ricotta füllung und an zutaten brauchen
wir 200 gramm blattspinat ich habe zb
gesperrt 250 gramm recorder käse eine
knoblauchzehe etwas olivenöl salz hier
habe ich eine italienischen hartkäse
einen pro wohl ohne da brauche ich 150
gramm etwas muskatnuss und pfeffer und
ich starte jetzt direkt mit dem spinat
und zwar muss ich dir in der pfanne
etwas anbieten damit einfach in sich
zusammenfällt
und falls jetzt keinen baby spinat
bekommt sondern nur großen normalen
spinat müsse den vorher einfach bisschen
klein schneiden aber die blätter sind ja
so schön klein
die können auch so nehmen sie zeige
unterschiedlichen baby spieler und in
china unterdessen hat kleinere feinere
blätter und der andere sind halt ganz
große blätter ist so fein
deswegen nehme ich jetzt halt ein baby
spielen macht es hat sich aber auch noch
die knoblauchzehen die habe ich grob
geschnitten weil ich mich ist gleich er
noch durch
das fällt jetzt gleich in sich zusammen
gebt einfach kurz den deckel drauf in
der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon
mal den käse fein reiben und zwar
brauche ich da 150 gramm und ich habe
jetzt diesen pro bowl ohne genommen weil
er einfach sehr lecker schmeckt ihr
könnt natürlich auch ein paar massage
beim anderen italienischen hartkäse
nehmen daher hat jetzt 44 prozent fett
in der trockenmasse und neulich war ich
in der käsetheke im globus und da habe
ich gelernt dass fett in der
trockenmasse nicht unbedingt abzug nach
fettgehalt heißt deswegen gehe ich total
gerne die käsetheke
das heißt er hat eigentlich in also
einen absoluten fettgehalt oder weniger
und 44 prozent halt in der trockenmasse
und ich dachte als kind immer das heißt
fed in tropfen
dabei heißt das fett in der trockenmasse
und wir haben natürlich kaufen anderl
ich jemals wollte ich eigentlich aber
dem gasnetz und pro wohl ohne hat
übrigens auch so eine geschützte
herkunftsbezeichnung das heißt man darf
sie nur so nennen wenn er von dort kommt
murat mensch warst du bei mir alles
lernen schon wahnsinn
da kommt mir risiko vor
so beim spinat ab und zu auch
durchführen
das sieht man mal wie stark der
zusammenfällt
jetzt kann ich den spinat noch würzen
mit salz und pfeffer
jetzt schaue ich auf dem herd aus denn
die flüssigkeit ist fast verdunstet und
muskatnuss kommt auch frisch geräten mit
dazu so jetzt fühle ich den spinat um in
einen kleinen mixa damit ich ihn
zerkleinern kann also ihr könnt einen
großen optional durch nehmen aber ich
habe halt ein kleiner
es riecht lecker
jetzt gebe ich den spinat mit zum käse
und da kommt auch direkt der rekorder
käse mit dazu den reporter käse bekommen
oder ja überall wo es auch mascarpone
gibt ich stehe im kontakt mit augen käse
ja frischkäse normalen trikot dann
findet ricotta kanada zwei italienische
messen jetzt gebe ich noch mein geld mit
rein für die bindung habe ich freunde
vergessen zu erwähnen bei den zutaten
und dann haben jetzt auch gleich die
füllung schon fertig die soll sie an der
stelle jetzt nochmal abschmecken ob er
noch salz oder per fax oder etwas
muskatnuss braucht darf ich abschmecken
ich freue mich hier ganz kurz auf von
michael kraus und dann geht es gleich
weiter
die füllung fühle ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel denn damit geht es später
etwas einfacher da kann ich die füllung
zur seite stellen und gleich den teig
ausrollen
jetzt nehme ich den teig und hat er ihn
erstmal und arbeitet jetzt mit der
hälfte
ich halte den teig jetzt in meiner
nudelmaschine aus mit der kitchen aid
wir könnten auch im ausschuss starb
auswahl wie sie aus dem käse derzeit
wirklich aus wie käse wenn er jetzt
bisschen klebt nehmen da einfach ein
bisschen mehl außen rum
so jetzt drücke ich ihnen kurz flach es
gibt auch so nudel maschinen die man der
hand kurbelt aber so hat man halt immer
beide hände frei deswegen finde ich das
ganz praktisch
dann geht es auch ganz schnell jetzt
starte ich erstmal bei stufe 1
haltet ihr den einfach mal zusammen weil
ich möchte jetzt richtig schöne große
lasagne platten
und wenn ihr dann die volle breite jetzt
hier ausgenutzt hat könnte den teig
immer dünner rollen
ich habe jetzt erst mal die
nudelmaschine weg gestellt um euch
einfach zu zeigen wie ich jetzt fühle
normalerweise mache ich immer den
kompletten nudelteig legten an da vorne
auf meine holzplatte weil da habe ich
ganz viel platz und dann fühle ich eben
alles aber damit der diskothek mache das
jetzt kurz zu und ich hab jetzt übrigens
die andere hälfte des teigs eingepackt
damit sie mich austrocknet nämlich eine
nudel platte wie gesagt wenn ihr so eine
ganze fläche habt können jetzt auch die
ganze platte nehmen und ich halte jetzt
ungefähr hier
da spritzt sich jetzt die füllung drauf
deswegen eignet sich da eben in
spritzbeutel super und wenn jetzt keinen
spritzbeutel ab können wir natürlich
auch in gefrierbeutel nehmen oder auch
mit einem teelöffel arbeiten und die
spritzbeutel kann man übrigens auch
immer wieder verwenden also man muss sie
nur kurz aus waschen und trocknen lassen
jetzt spritze ich hier so kleine
häufchen drauf
jetzt reichlich ein bisschen wasser her
zwischen rein damit die platten gleich
gut kleben
jetzt setzt sich die zweite nudel platte
drauf und sie sie auch leicht in form
und drückt sie so ein bisschen an
jetzt hab ich hier so ein ravioli
schneider und zwar schneidet der
einerseits die julis durcheinanders
jetzt drückt das sie fest und damit
fahrt ihr einmal am rand entlang
außerdem bekommen die so ein richtig
tolles muster und daneben auch hier in
der mitte
und wenn ihr diesen ravioli schneider
übrigens nicht habt könnte auch die raúl
ist mit einem messer auseinander
schneiden und dann mit der gabel
zusammenrücken
dann habt ihr auch so ein tolles musste
und ich finde so an sich also im rat
auch eben gesagt dass er macht man sowas
eigentlich selber sowas macht man selber
weil man dann einfach die zutaten sich
selber aussuchen kann
und ich finde es geht halt auch super
schnell und so vereinfacht und man kann
den geschmack eben selbst variiert man
kann selber entscheiden wie die ravioli
schmeckt und ich denke man schätzt dass
auf ihm er wäre ja ich finde es ist also
richtig ein hauptgericht muss sich jetzt
erst richtig zu schätzen
ich habe jetzt alle ravioli geformt
samira hat ihre portion auch fertig
gemacht wird einfach immer den teig
genommen den ich am rand weggeschnitten
habe den teig könnte entweder weiter
benutzen und dann eben noch mal welche
machen oder ihr gibt es einfach ihrem
kind und die macht dann schöne nudel
formen daraus super die darf sie auch
gleich selber kochen und essen und ich
möchte jetzt die ravioli gleich abkochen
aber ich werde jetzt gleich zuerst eine
tomatensoße machen und für die
tomatensoße brauchen wir folgende
zutaten und zwar habe ich hier olivenöl
2 3 esslöffel dann brauchen wir zwei
dosentomaten den 800 gramm etwas
tomatenmark so etwa 40 gramm eine
zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe habe ich hier
drin
salz pfeffer und zucker und später
nehmen wir noch basilikum aus dem
hintergrund ihren so ich kann jetzt
schon mal olivenöl in die pfanne geben
eine tiefe waren habe ich da jetzt
übrigens und schneit jetzt knoblauch und
zwiebel in feine würfel
jetzt gebe ich die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehen mit zum und brate sie
jetzt etwa 2 3 minuten bei mittlerer
hitze an
jetzt gebe ich noch das tomatenmark mit
rein wie gesagt 40 gramm rate des ganz
kurz mit an und löschte dann die
zwiebeln mit den formaten ab jetzt habe
ich hier ein bisschen wasser eingefüllt
und kann die dosen damit ausspülen
dann habt ihr auch den letzten rest und
gibt es auch mehr dazu
dass sich die sauce aufkochen und würze
jetzt auch gleich mit salz pfeffer und
mit dem zucker der zucker hilft einfach
dabei dass die tomaten nicht mehr also
dass man diese säure nicht mehr so
schmeckt und das ist eben automatica
schmeckt also hebt den tomaten geschmack
und später gebe ich dann auf den
basilikum mit dazu den habe ich jetzt
hier schon etwas gezupft und werden
jetzt noch klein hacken und kann jetzt
in der zwischenzeit schon mal auch das
nudelwasser aufsetzen
in einem großen topf denn zuerst bis
jetzt diese soße fertig sein und dann
können wir gleich die ravioli abkochen
damit eben wird es später alles
zusammenfügen können
kann ich die soße einmal durchrühren und
mittlerweile ist auch mein nudelwasser
gekocht die soße dürfte etwa 5 minuten
kochen
jetzt gebe ich etwas salz in das wasser
und dann können da auch die ravioli
schon jetzt mit so einer stelle deine
kommen dann zum schluss noch einen
eigenen topf und wenn die dann an der
oberfläche schwimmen so etwa in 23
minuten dann sind sie durch
jetzt gebe ich die basilikumblätter mit
in die soße verwickelt sondern kann man
die soße auch schon abschalten
die erste portion ravioli bin jetzt
schon fertig die kann ich bereits in die
sauce geben dann kleben sie auch nicht
zusammen
ich habe sie das nur bisschen abtropfen
lassen verrührte sitzt durch dann sind
auch gleich die deines auch gleich die
zweite portion fertig und ich kann
gleich anrichten
jetzt in die ravioli fertig und ich kann
sie anrichten
die zweite portion mache ich jetzt
gleich auch noch in die pfanne zur sauce
aber die tanne smith kline darf ich den
papa auch bisschen parmesan draufmachen
wirklich ab stück also bin ich frisch
gerieben aktion frisch gekauftes ist
dagegen aroma
ja das stimmt es ist einfach wahnsinn
guck mal wie es aussieht ist richtig und
damit du weißt dass du hier auch er hat
ich mach dir ein stück parmesan essen
also ich finde auch dass ich ein super
hauptgericht es macht auch richtig spaß
das zuzubereiten samira hat dann auch
bisschen ihre nudeln selber gemacht darf
ist die ravioli mit ihrer mit ihren
eigenen also die eigenen nudeln essen
wie die ressource und ich find's einfach
genial und man kann die ravioli übrigens
auch vorbereiten
ich habe jetzt eine riesengroße menge
gemacht also wir sind hier auch gleich
zu vier zu fünft mit samira und werden
das zusammen essen aroma kann sie auch
so aufbewahren oder zum beispiel noch
nicht gekocht einfach einfrieren
dann ist das einfach schön schichten mit
bissen pergamentpapier oder papa peter
zwischen können sie einfrieren und
einfach bei bedarf in heißes wasser
schmeißen und habe dann schnell eure
eigenen fertig regionen genommen können
auch einigen einmal im jahr so drei vier
kilo zu machen wir es bei den türkischen
mantel also bei diesen türkischen
kleinen maultaschen
da trifft man sich dann macht es
zusammen 45 kilo wird eingefroren und
dann kann man es einfach immer wieder
aufkochen und ich finde aber auch man
sollte jetzt auch zu diesem gericht
kauft gar nichts anderes servieren
allianz aber danach fleischer irgendwas
mir dass du die konzentration völlig auf
den raum ein sehr leckeres rezept wenn
ihr das gerne nachmachen volt steht das
rezept für euch auch sally blog.de
und wir lassen uns jetzt schmecken räume
gleich auf und gehen und bitten an die
frische luft oder zum tierpark gehen hat
das machen also bis zum nächsten mal in
den tierpark dach der windpocken ja
nachher schnee tut sich ganze tiere
anstecken
erst mit dem gleiche raus rücken legen